pensate a un robot che conoscete
forse gli umanoidi della carpa
challenger la gara di robotica più
famosa al mondo è il top della
tecnologia robotica di oggi ora pensate
a un animale il gatto di casa
qual è la prima differenza che vi viene
in mente il robot è rigido
ora pensate a un colpo non così so che
siamo abituati a mangiarlo soprattutto a
livorno dove vivo questo può il po che
cosa di bellissimo agli occhi di europ o
tipo non ha niente di rigido e il suo
corpo si deforma si adatta a spazi anche
molto piccoli rispetto alle sue
dimensioni il braccio del polpo si
flette in ogni punto e in ogni direzione
e poi si allunga e si accorcia questo
per un robotico è davvero difficile da
immaginare ma soprattutto più importante
il braccio del polpo si può irrigidire
in alcune parti quando serve diventano
spesso di scheletro modificabile e poi
colpi non sanno solo afferrare e
manipolare gli oggetti ma sanno anche
camminare nuotare tutte cose che ci
interessano nei robot le vogliamo vedere
anche nei robot si dice anche che i
colpi siano molto intelligenti anche i
nostri naturalmente hanno imparato a
svitare barattoli ma non sono questo
corpo così particolare quasi speciale a
renderle intelligenti
in effetti la visione moderna
dell'intelligenza artificiale sposta
molto l'attenzione dal cervello al corpo
e ci dice che non si può sviluppare
intelligenza solo con il cervello serve
anche un corpo in corpo fisico che
interagisca con l'ambiente ci dice anche
che alcune azioni alcuni movimenti non
sono soltanto controllati dal cervello
del sistema nervoso ma in qualche modo
vengono eseguite dal corpo stesso come
quando camminiamo e il ginocchio ci
aiuta a compensare alcune asperità del
terreno
ma qual è il segreto del corpo del polpo
il braccio del polpo a molti muscoli e
quindi ci immaginiamo che vengono
controllati dal sistema nervoso per
compiere i movimenti che vediamo ma
guardate cosa succede a questo braccio
di silicone soltanto un cono allungato
alla stessa morfologia per ordine
braccio del polpo e alle stesse
proprietà meccaniche la stessa densità e
la stessa cedevolezza in acqua che sono
ambiente se applichiamo un'accelerazione
alla base vediamo un movimento che è
molto simile a quello che l'animale fa
quando deve raggiungere un oggetto ma
allora non sarà che anche il polpo
sfrutta questo movimento passivo e non
controlla completamente questo movimento
di origini
qual è appunto il segreto del corpo del
volto e questo è la struttura muscolare
del braccio si chiama muscolare stat
ci sono dei muscoli longitudinali e
trasversali obliqui e la combinazione
delle contrazioni di questi muscoli
origina tutti i movimenti che osserviamo
nell'animale le contrazioni
longitudinali citando le flessioni con
tutte le direzioni mentre l'allungamento
si ottiene contraente
i muscoli trasversali con i lanciato di
nali rilassati che si lasciano allungare
così viceversa le contrazioni dei
longitudinali se il trasversale sono
rilassati fanno accorciare il braccio ma
la cosa più importante che l'eco
contrazioni cioè le contrazioni
simultanee fanno irrigidire il braccio è
qui che diventa uno scheletro
modificabile ecco allora che cercando di
imitare la combinazione di queste
contrazioni trasversali e longitudinali
si può costruire un braccio
semplicissimo anche solo con un cono di
silicone e dei cavi all'interno che in
acqua a dei movimenti molto simili a
quelli che abbiamo osservato negli
animali un vero e proprio muscolo
artificiale ancora non è stato inventato
però ci sono dei materiali che hanno le
proprie tanti restanti le leghe a
memoria di forma hanno la proprietà di
tornare a una forma originaria quando
vengono riscaldati ecco allora che
possiamo costruire delle molle con
questi materiali che quando vengono
riscaldate facendo passare una corrente
si contraggono e così possiamo
ricostruire un vero e proprio muscolar
hydra state robotico con contrazioni
longitudinali e trasversali e quindi si
può costruire mente il braccio che ne
acqua si flette come il braccio del
polpo e si allunga anche con le
contrazioni trasversali per la nostra
molle
in questo modo sono riuscito a costruire
un vero e proprio poi propotipo imitando
i vari meccanismi di semplificazione che
se servono e l'animale anche la nottata
la camminata sfruttano l'interazione con
l'acqua per camminare braccio usa solo
due braccia e posteriori per spingersi
avanti sfruttando l'acqua che lo
sostiene e questo si può riprodurre in
robotica per esempio solo con un motore
per
braccio è una grossa semplificazione a
patto però che si mettono bene le
proprietà meccaniche del braccio e così
si può realizzare un vero e proprio
colpo robotico con oltre braccia per
fare che cosa si può anche immaginare di
metterlo al lavoro il nostro polpo
robotico per esempio in mare visto che
dal mare viene e quindi si può
immaginare un nuovo tipo di robot marini
che a differenza di quelle esistenti
possono camminare sul fondale possono
anche andare su una barriera corallina
sono morbidi all'interno di un relitto
anche in medicina
il polpo robotico ha trovato
applicazione per costruire un endoscopio
che possa essere morbido quando deve
muoversi all'interno del corpo umano ma
poi irrigidirsi in parte quando deve
compiere delle operazioni così come
sempre in ambito biomedico
stiamo costruendo un braccio che potrà
aiutare le anziane a lavarsi sotto la
doccia
ma il grande merito del polpo robotico è
quello che il polpo ci ha insegnato è
stato portare una piccola grande
rivoluzione robotica mettere in
discussione le sue fondamenta e dare
vita a quella che a livello
internazionale conosciuta come software
robotics la robotica soft oggi ci sono
tantissime truppe di ricetta in tutto il
mondo nelle migliori università che
studiano la soft robotics e sviluppano
troppo soft il futuro della soft
robotics io spero che scompaia
non si parlerà più di robot soft sarà
semplicemente il modo di costruire robot
nel futuro